good morning John we just got the first
images from the James Webb Space
Telescope and a lot of people it seems
are feeling a bit small right now maybe
humbled maybe insignificant but here's
something weird I'm actually not sure if
I feel very small right now or
very big
so when you look at a structure like the
cosmic Cliffs with seven light year tall
Peaks or a Deep Field image that you
cannot put your pinky finger on without
covering several galaxies it makes sense
to think okay
so why do we think that anything that
happens here on Earth matters at all
and there are really good human answers
to that question answer is like we give
our universe meaning we matter to each
other but there are also maybe some like
kind of objective answers
would we understand that an area in the
sky the size of a grain of sand contains
thousands of galaxies that each contain
billions of stars and we say I feel
insignificant now that is not a way of
saying nothing matters it's an instinct
that something matters but that that
mattering is spread throughout what
appears to be a basically infinite
universe and so we don't matter
something matters just not us because we
are too small to matter but I wonder
is size the right measure I've got a
kind of okay understanding of how the
universe works like not great but maybe
a bit better than average and one thing
that seems to be basically the case is
that there are a bunch of practically
infinite fields that cause particles to
exist and interact in a number of ways
and as evidenced by the presence of
oxygen and hydrogen Spectra in galaxies
billions of light years away the rules
appear to be consistent throughout the
whole universe now this is all very
complicated but it's also not it's just
physics doing physics things but while
the universe is astoundingly Big indeed
very possibly infinite in size it's not
that big in time now you might say Hank
actually 13.7 billion years seemed like
a very long time like practically
infinite but no the universe is Young
compared to both infinity and compared
to its eventual lifespan life on Earth
is one continual chemical system that
dates back 3.7 billion years which means
that this wild Frolic that includes
everything from Brachiosaurus to BTS has
existed for 27
of the lifetime of the universe
we do not take up much space but we have
taken up a lot of time
so that's one way we are bigger than we
might think but here's another
the vast majority of the particles in
the universe
do not know they exist
they have never wanted something they've
never looked at something and found it
beautiful they have never built a space
telescope and when I say like vast
majority I mean that the number of
particles that are part of any system
with wants and Sensations is so small
that they may as well be ignored but we
can agree they should not be ignored
because they are very strange and very
different and very beautiful and they
know things about themselves and about
each other in your head you have around
the same number of neurons as there are
stars in the Milky Way galaxy
and those neurons are much smaller than
stars but they are in fact more ordered
and you could argue that each one is
more complex
if you think galaxies are amazing just
wait until you find out
about you
now are we the only chemical system to
have built a space telescope no the way
I understand the universe that is an
impossibility but it also does not seem
very common for the universe to find
paths toward waking up
and to be a part of that
it feels very big
John I'll see you on Tuesday